c'est un homme qui entre 78 à 91 a tué
dépec et brûlés 16 homosexuels c'était
un fou il y a pas d'autres mots et
aujourd'hui et bien c'est un tel
événement que tout ce qui portait les
lunettes les t-shirts et tout ça ça
devient des goodies ça se vend dans le
monde entier évidemment alors je précise
déjà que dans la série tout ce qui dit
mot à mot ça a été repris c'est
transcription de la police donc vraiment
il va y avoir notamment deux
documentaires sur Netflix de samedi
encore ou cette fois-ci on va entendre
les vrais vrais voix mais tous les
enregistrements mais pour vous dire les
lunettes donc 150000 euros l'être
manuscrite de son père 2500 euros un
dessin d'école qu'il avait fait petit il
avait fait un petit cœur 1500 euros une
bible qu'il possédait en prison mais
10000 euros voilà vous êtes choqué ou
pas comment tous ces goodies
mais pourquoi t'es pas choqué Benoît là
j'avoue je suis pas mais je vais quand
même des fois de mon parti je sais lire
tu sais lire
alors moi je suis choqué le fait qu'au
moment de les lunettes originales qui
devrait appartenir à l'enquête et aux
policiers mais en revanche les
références et les répliques des lunettes
pour se déguiser en lui pour Halloween